he loves it yeah yeah that is cute it's
cute it's very cute
yeah I disagree I think we should list
and then like equality thank you
[Music]
hi everybody it's the Millennium
Falcon's show with me the Millennial
Falcon Jenny and here today I have James
Clements of mr. Sunday movies hello I'm
both of those things I'm he's Australian
yeah I am well do you know why we're
here today
vaguely did you hear the news all the
new I heard so much news there's it's
it's on the news in particular yes Colin
Trevorrow is dead it's fire yeah so why
do you think it happened what I think it
happened press release but they had
different visions yes the studio and
Colin hmm and I think that means that
maybe they had good visions and hand bad
visions potentially I I think I think
off the back of the book of Henri which
you have seen yeah I have written
massive yep we weren't seen at night you
have to experience it I know I know I
know I know what happens and I was told
before this was I was like you should go
and say it because I'm sure there's
parts that people forgot to tell you
there's a lot there to unpack the key
points that I got is there's a genius
child who runs his mother's life who's a
drunk lunatic he also discovered that
his neighbor was being abused by her
father so he leaves a series of audio
tapes instructing his mother how to
assassinate this man who's from Breaking
Bad if their audio tapes what is the
book of Henri I don't know it's a
redundant journal I think he just also
made audio tapes because in the film
medium it's easier to have him talking
out loud that's a really good point it
makes no sense
yeah so that's why he's obviously no
longer doing Star Wars yeah I think that
maybe Kathleen Kennedy like someone
slipped a DVD under her office door it
was just like for your consideration
right right what's this book of Henri
pops it in and no more jobs for Colin I
read that he wanted to get back to kind
of he missed the indie film experience
and he because he went from indie film
to Jurassic total control so he wants to
get it I think the only scripts bad
enough that they would say under total
control tonight yes yeah
did you enjoy Jurassic world I didn't
dislike Jurassic world and a lot of
people did I'm pretty much like
dinosaurs it's fine I think it's one of
those things where like he did a good
job I just kind of like just hit these
baits we need a big fight at the end we
need someone running in hi
we need Raptors with cameras yeah but
Ron like dogs yeah the high heels thing
yeah and that's one thing is like after
you see Book of Henry you can't stop
thinking about how he treats his female
characters all right no watch safety not
guaranteed
after seeing book of Henry Shaw and then
I was like oh oh every woman in this
movie is there to have sex with a man in
this movie is that what that is yeah I
enjoyed it I remember it's really
popular
yeah but yeah I think that may be
considering star wars has a female
protagonist yes maybe he encountered
some difficulty in in setting that up
mm-hmm and making it good and I think
he's a man who's very blind to his own
shortcomings so I think he's writing
like this script is going really well
cuz he didn't he still didn't understand
what was wrong with book of Henry after
it came out okay yeah I said well he -
he's credit he went everywhere and he
showed and he talked about it to
everybody you know but it's too many
things in that movie that's what it's
saying it's a lot going on yeah it's a
lot of different movies at once there's
also a beautiful ballet symbolizing
child abuse so I made like a little list
of things I think Colin might have
included in his script for Star Wars
Episode nine what's the title snark no
yeah okay good um I think that it's
possible Colin tried to introduce a
character named Henry who's a young Jedi
prodigy just points out to Ray how much
stuff she's doing wrong yeah right yeah
okay and so does that Jedi die and then
leaves a series of hollow recordings he
does well a holocron this annoying
precocious young boy who's like here
okay you idiot I'm going to tell you how
to kill a man with a sniper rifle
here's that we're gonna get Snoke I want
them to be aged and it can Skywalker
Jake Lloyd and I want him to be holocron
boy bring that full circle oh man
styluses
right so it does doesn't it yeah what do
you think what do you think he would
have put in a script what do you want to
do if you take a core idea from Jurassic
world which for me was like the Raptors
was a big part of that the Raptors
turning good so safe in takes her like a
like a troop of Tusken Raiders and he
translated to fall
him Finn would use these Tusken Raiders
to go on attack smoke but Snoke is also
a Tuscan Raider and he gives them like a
rabbit to eat after they I thought it
would be great if they kind of setup ray
and Luke Skywalker is these kind of like
platonic colleagues and then suddenly
there's like a scene seemingly out of
nowhere where Poe is like you like him
don't you and then the audience has to
be like what is that where this is what
this is and then they're like sitting
around a campfire on their Island and
they just start making out okay all
right I guess they were they were
romantic Oh any chemistry but I guess
this is what this is this is Star Wars
now against the shoulder but okay yeah
well you know the stranger things have
happened
yes you could take the time travel
element of safety not guaranteed and
just go yes Star Wars has time travel
now so maybe they bring young Han Solo
to the present day too apparently and
they can bring they can just bring the
cast that's being wasted in that movie
that's probably gonna get canceled and
just bring that young Han Solo to play
young con solo in the current timeline
yeah so it'll step even more on the toes
of purist fans who don't like them
recasting Han Solo part of me wants to
say Tom travel because people would go
insane yeah yeah I think it'd be great
if Princess Leia had like a story arc
where she keeps trying to make military
decisions she's in like her command
center and then Admiral Ackbar is like
our disagree I think we should the list
and then like equality thank you
I've been practicing it's real good and
then at the end of the film
like whatever Leia was trying to do can
go catastrophic Alire all right we're
feeling that Akbar was right the whole
time yeah he knows what he's doing badly
and all right yeah do you think I can't
they cancelled that because she passed
away yeah I think they're gonna use
mocap oh yeah of course yeah I have Andy
Serkis play two roles he could
definitely do it yeah oh I think it's
possible also that it's not his script
maybe he just CC Kathleen Kennedy on the
email where he was talking to Mack about
her alright yeah well that dad is the
thing that happens a hundred percent
yeah just awkward work tension like
whenever they had a board meeting he
would show up in flip-flops and like
board shorts and they'd just be like you
know what we said business casual
but it's a little unprofessional and
Kathleen would kind of make comments
like oh those look comfortable and he
like didn't pick up on it oh yeah yeah
so um who do you think is gonna direct
the new one I think probably Rian
Johnson I think it's a safe choice carry
him over like my oh yeah my on the
grievance is that he might be just burnt
out like imagine doing two Star Wars we
know anything pressure and all the
studio involvement probably makes it an
exhausting process and we don't know if
he enjoyed doing it exactly I'm sure he
would say that he did but we don't
actually know no maybe he found it
taxing and maybe he felt stifled and
doesn't want to come back I kind of
prematurely hoping he does do nine
because I'm just optimistic this will be
good I mean he put in the evil bb-8 I
wanted so much right yeah literally said
I wanted an evil black bb-8 that kills
people
how's it gonna kill people it's gonna be
cutting throats yeah well I was saying
that like me know huh bb-8 his little
compartment pops open and there's a
little arm with like a thumbs up oh yeah
he would have a little hand holding that
sharp knife needs ghosts and he just
slices everybody through their necks
abdomen yep like it's one of the most
gruesome scenes we've ever seen it he's
just rolling through the ED track I'm
just spitting up like he doubles back
he's crushing it and like he looks like
he's enjoying it and he like gleeful
sounds better yeah there's just blood
droplets flying everywhere
he loves it yeah yeah that is cute it's
cute it's very cute yeah yeah that's a
dominance thing you're putting this one
on top of that one yeah I was like oh I
really loved that bb-8 but now I've got
this new one it's all news mate so yeah
I just kind of put this one on top I
thought about just getting rid of that
one but we'll see you could give it away
as a millennial Falcon prize to the
Rangers comment oh no it'll be for the
the best fan to give me their
five-foot-tall pork alright yeah many of
them can enter however many people want
to yes but the best poor guy receive
will get that you're still on the hunt
for the best pork the giant pork I like
that you committed well one thing I
think might have happened that caused a
lot of tension is I heard that Colin had
a weird fixation on King Kong so he
would constantly like every week he'd
send an email to Kathleen like we need
King Kong to be the final villain the
great fights in this movie and the
studio was like we don't know I'm King
Kong like he's not even from Jurassic
world like where's King Kong I tried to
compromise I like will make Snoke 80
feet tall and like him everybody he just
kept saying it has to be Kong cat
listening to me Kong and then he would
just send her emails where the subject
line was it has to be Kong and the body
was pleased Kathleen do you think we're
ever gonna find out what really goes on
with these thousand Conger yeah but you
only like 20 years to be like yeah man
it was I was so drunk yeah yeah no I
think he'd come on and just be like I
just didn't feel appreciated oh and it's
just sad that he's sad yeah I also heard
he's horribly afraid of motion capture
suits like being stuck in one oh so CNN
right so like they were trying to work
around it but if you have like Lupita
Nyong'o walk into the studio and you go
that's why there's a reduced role yeah
they're frightening to him because he's
seen the end result and he doesn't
understand how they make that leap so he
thinks they're witches right okay with
that yeah yeah well I think it's about
that time you know what time it's bloody
general grievances time isn't it hey
bloody well is mate I hate my accent in
hindsight when I can hear it around
Americans it's very off-putting it is
the same thing so now it's time to hear
from you the fans all the viewers at
least and it's time for you to leave oh
man because I feel like this is a
segment I could contribute to in my own
way I don't think so no no I feel like
I'm thoroughly prepared without where
did you get that I made this looks like
mine i watch your show every week I've
been this is actually hand-forged what's
on the car it's my own general
grievances not towards you it's for its
for people on my youtube channel I hate
you yeah people hating me okay we'll get
more than um after this episode comes
out right but yeah let's let's here
all right read your first question I
would love to okay it's not a question
it's more of a comment a statement this
is from cypher 64 why do you shout nerd
your YouTube channel is pointless
AAF now get cancer
I'm sorry sir sorry well do things good
I used to be at a shoe of my strategy is
never respond alright let's see what my
fans have to say they like me a lot more
than yours oh good you all right
backstage bum said I don't know how to
react to her she always acts like she's
ready to cry and I don't know if that's
on purpose if everything she does is on
purpose or is sarcastic I don't know
well nothing I do is sarcastic and I am
always ready to cry and it's never on
purpose that was emotional for me to
watch yeah yeah me too
what's your next life's comment this is
from acid smooth dude you're a mone
whiny little shite yeah small doses of
you might work maybe I do actually think
that's true I think I am better in small
doses people like you should do videos
every day
that was quite charitable yeah I
absolutely should not do videos every
day
no you should you should do videos every
year just every time a new Star War
comes out that's a great idea
mmm-hmm this is helpful you just maybe
won Game of Thrones video per season
yes definitely yeah pace yourself this
is my final one from Gertrude Perkins
why the eff it says the other thing but
I okay that's why the F do so many
people watch mine mind rotting drivel
like this from some fat sweaty nerds sat
in his bedroom who knows nothing about
anything get an effing job this this is
what I do sort of now this is it calling
they call me yeah Oh sweaty and then it
says Kong sucks
yeah that's so mean you know he has just
kick a guy when he's down Oh
now I have one more comment
it's very eloquent it's a long comment
from Jerry glazed cherry glaze says okay
family so wearing and stupid she lowered
the Scheldt instead of dying like she
should have Ray was too perfect really
good Ben while he was lame because he
was not funny but I supposed to think he
was but that is why ray and Finn were
still there I don't understand hype with
characters and Star Wars
bought a Fett did nothing in one movie
then dies in most simple way ever and
people fall over this guy I don't get it
and I don't know if I am missing
something or I see a side caricature
basically an extra become an icon phasma
was supposed to be the lord of the
stormtroopers and load the shell ads it
would have been better to have her
killed resisting lowering the shields
that would have added something to the
film and to the characters instead we
got what we got
I 100% agree with all of your comments
I'm so glad that you decided to come
here after you saw Star Wars you know
what's interesting about that as well it
was perfectly worded but you can't read
that well that's what happened there
right yeah a great comment yeah alright
what said what we're all thinking it's
time to go oh right thank you for having
me
yeah we'll leave the shoes first thank
you goodbye farewell goodbye why goodbye
okay thank you thank you better not be
sweaty yeah